Andrew: This meeting.
Andrew: Yes, you are I. You just opened another tab. It's understanding. Zoom, private closed document signed in without 0 sign, in, without 0 link and switching just meeting control. This meeting is the end with leave meeting Button got it, but enter sign in without the area. This meeting is being reported.
Andrew: Hello! My name is Andrew, and today I'm going to be investigating the Upskill platform for fable. I'm. Going to be trying to take the first module in the course getting started with web development.
Andrew: I'm doing this on Chrome's latest pressure, which believe is 108,
Andrew: and I'm doing this for just 2,021.
Andrew: So i'm going to begin show password switch off
Andrew: by logging in. I already have the credentials all inserted into the fields, so
Andrew: I will just hit
Andrew: be for button log it, button.
but to actively present.
Andrew: signed in without 0. Dashgoodal pro to activate rest space. Our vertical okay, good, so stop it narrating with the control. I'll go to the top of the pitch Control home.
Andrew: Same page links. Dip the main content, and i'll arrow down. I'll try this skip link here, and the same page links to the main content. Courses vertical parking main region. Same page links to the main content main region.
Andrew: and it narrated, like Joshua's focus, cut, move, but it didn't actually move apparently like graphical navigation list of like the dashboard link cordless, and that we can under. We're heading level, one courses heading level 2 like available
Andrew: until I find the course. I'm looking for any level. 3 links. If you're on the table. This course will give you a refresh your overall pros like that missing depending level. 3 links that page for a party cop Video: Microsoft Overall proper setting level, freely applicating for work
Andrew: getting started the Web development setting level freely. That's what i'm looking for.
Andrew: Now, i'm just gonna I noticed that it's also a link. So what I'm going to do is just be safe, as I'm going to navigate down line my line just to see there's also like a get started. Button. Welcome to getting started in web development. This course will provide information on web development and general accessibility of a developer experience, overall progress call and have attending level 3 linkedin production to accessibility for Canada Post 71.
Andrew: Okay. So it is the actual heading I need to hit. Enter on. So I will jump back with shift, plus each getting started in web development. Any level, free link
Andrew: getting started in Web development vertical bar label Upskill. Whether you learn to the programs and technology, right? You know, i'll stop at narrating with control
Andrew: that i'm starting to control home and I h for heading red from heading level to getting started in web development. Any level one, no certain navigating down my my line overall Progress Co. And 17% complete heading level. 2 course details welcome to getting started on web development and general accessibility of a developer experience.
Whether you are new to the programs and technologies. Describe to your alone batch Time, veteran of the same. The course offers content for new discourse.
Andrew: and i'm just naming it down again, line by line with the generator as an emphasis. I'm. Learning for people. We usually there are 4 parts to this course, and modules for
Andrew: started on 0, one slash, 10 sl 2,023 completed, all right, so it looks like some of these might have already been completed by someone else. So i'm just going to look for a link to try and find the first module. 4 out of 23 activities will continue learning. The commissing image is cutting level 3 adding started a Web Development course completed.
like what is a web developer completed
Andrew: like what a completely about the web development, of course, might be the first part I'm. Not sure status activity
Andrew: just gonna navigate up
Andrew: line by line with the up there. They're still cutting Level 3, that and started web developments and one table with 2 columns in 6 of activity.
Andrew: Alright, so you have activity. I'm: in the table now. So when you use table number yeah.
Andrew: let me try that again. Cable navigation commands to control Alt and the arrow keys. So move right with control. All right, Arrow status columns and the
Andrew: Okay. I see the end of the row, so i'll move back across the
Andrew: top of these column headers with the control left Arrow activity column, one beginning to vote all right, so it's just the 2 columns. So now i'll move down one row with control all down there. Link about the Web Development Port. Slow to
Andrew: like. What is the web developer. I'll read, I'm just gonna check for here, just to see if these are the actual modules or these are within this first module link web development as a career oval link the Us. Code and get a link that slackers in the bottom of column.
Andrew: and then i'm at the bottom. So i'll do control right here
Andrew: the section, so I I never get it up the column with control up there on. Now. I'm going to enter on this first one about the program.
Enter.
People than 2 months are showing code in the dark room with orange backlight and graphics getting started in forces.
Andrew: and I don't know where I am on the pace, so go to the top with control.
Andrew: It's sure heading here, getting started in web development, setting level 2 side menu.
Andrew: Okay, so there's a side navigation menu, I'm sure hitting each You're heading one more time. Of course I would like that in little. There we go. Same page links to the activity, cutting level for you that, and started the web of the same page which you've selected, i'm sure hitting the skipped activity link to see if this one works. Same page links to activity main region, skip the activity, same page, link.
Andrew: heading level 3 that installed the web, develop same page links different activity. Okay. So once again it narrated as if it moved. But the link actually did not move. Jazz's virtual PC. Curse or heading level 3 that it started the Web Development heading Level 5 button expanded that it started in web development. 4 slash 5 activities done. List of 5. Item link about the Web Development Course Link. What is the web developer?
Andrew: Okay. So apparently, even though I thought I hit, I activated the link for the about the program activity. It seems to taking me to an overview page. Look out the Web development ports, the web developer.
Andrew: Think about the web develop. So I hit. Enter on this first link about what I think about the Web Development Development Course, Enter
video transcript button collapsed. Getting started. The web developed that it same page links to the main Content main region.
Andrew: and i'm going to H for heading again right? I'm heading level to getting started in web development, setting level one side menu heading level. 2. Of course I would like that in level 2 alright. Here's the okay same page with step with activity heading level for you getting started on the Web development.
Andrew: So, hey, you're heading one more time. So I guess every page must have that. The outline at the top of it getting started in Web Development heading level bedding started with me as code heading Level 5 button Activity heading Level 2. Here we are. Okay. So this must be the actual activity. Same page we'll step, of course, outline heading level. 2 of the Web Development Course
Keyboard and two-month are showing code in the dark room with orange backlight and graphic heading level 3 learning outcome people in the dark room with orange backlight in graphic.
so that all text seems to be fine heading level 3 learning outcomes.
In this course you will get some general backgrounds on the skills and traits you might want for working in the Web Development, or you will also get an overview of Colonel List of 2 by one linkage will send you a code left fair, and opens no tap right far.
Andrew: Oh, excellent! So that link the actual tools will open, or any tab. If I open it, it could be used to create web pages, applications, and more to link the top left there, and opens the app right there.
Andrew: And again it's also telling me that what you link the top lip there and opens new tab right there. And yep, all this is opening Tab. That's wonderful to over managing the source code you create and collaborate on with others with. And perhaps most importantly, you'll get inside some fips based on my experience in the technology industry. You may have had some of the same experiences.
Andrew: So this is apparently the main lecture by the the person who created the course so hopefully, knowing others who want to similar path rates that can be a relevant call and curiosity, a willingness to learn the success there are. Drive your self activities with some items you can use to practice what you are learning, but overall you won't find the great deal of's to patch by that step guidance here. Instead, you will find general tips and approaches. You can use to learn more about any of the topics of interest, learning how to learn.
Andrew: Okay, and i'm just continuing to make you done one by one with down here a keys of setting level. 3 me, Kelly Ford Kelly is a white man with short, round bearer demise in the course windows. He is wearing the Navy polo shirt and tan kaki's like sitting in the light. We live in a room with a Retto Vibe.
Andrew: Oh, interesting
play button.
Andrew: Okay. And I guess we have a video here. I'll try playing this. I'll hit enter. Made me a video player button, but
window transfer button collapsed.
Andrew: We're a living room with what i'm here to talk about is just getting engaged with technical for me. One of the
Andrew: i'm i'm i'm i'm. I'm trying to find the button to stop and it's an
Andrew: i'm getting started with web development getting started with, because i'm sure you need to control here by turning up. 10 years later
Andrew: the web became popular.
Andrew: There we go, all right. What I did is I went to the bomb and hit the next lesson, because there's just whatever reason, when I hit that play button. All the controls through the for the video just seem to vanish. That's huge problem.
Because if
Andrew: I, as a user wanted to be able to pause it like, say, I had a phone call coming. I had to answer, or something else. I couldn't pause it. I'd have to go arrow back
Andrew: with the All Left Arrow key, and I hope that it took me back to the main lesson, or do what I just did here, and hit next lesson prematurely
getting started, and web the same page links to.
Andrew: So i'm going to go to the top of control home Heading started.
Andrew: Pause.
Andrew: apologies for that I just need to take a moment to review something. So getting started at the same page, let's get them.
Andrew: I'm going to go to the top of control home.
Andrew: and we're getting started with web development setting. Let's start with the Web development, and we're getting started with me as code heading Level 5 button to laptop. That's the web development that in level 3. So it's just continuing to hit each head and getting started in web development. And we're getting started with me as code heading Level 5 button to laptop. Okay, now I'm just going to arrow up just to make sure this is the actual Serve the activity with that link that's like a 0 one. Link me as code and the link web developer. Think about the okay, so I may have got a little to first. I'll hit shift, plus H to go to the previous center getting started in web development
Andrew: what he's done, and i'll move down on the that's interesting. The heading, I thought, started it apparently, and put me past the beginning parts, but the previous heading was the actual outline.
Andrew: So i'm just going to navigate very quickly past this with the Down Arrow key to go line my line past this 0 editing. Let's say, page links to the course outline heading Play Button Heading Level 2. What is the Web developer?
Play Button Progress, R.
Andrew: Rocket Star, Lip right, slacker, 00'clock to 5, 43, M. 0, Max, 343. Okay. So we have another video player. I: 43 volume lift bearing news up slash, now narrow keys to change right there, but
to the captions button menu
Andrew: settings button collapse. Enter a picture attached to that picture button settings button. So what i'm going to do to the caption is probably lift their news up. Slash! Now they'll keep that. I do want to test this to see this. The controls problem happens here. I can only lift there and use up to this volume, Control the main region, video, play frame, volume left there and use up slash. Now narrow keys to change right there, button to activate presenter
volume left, Fair news of slash, now narrow case to change right there.
volume, lift fair news of slash, now narrow keys to change right to the captions button meant volume lift, pair, 0%, M. 0, Max. One
Andrew: tell you you left there, and he was up there, and he's like there. It didn't seem to open anything. Tell you Left there, and he was up Slash now, narrow keys to change right there, button
Andrew: volume lifts how you lip there! And he was a trading in her again. 100% left, right, Slider.
Andrew: Oh, there we go now. I got a slider, so i'm going to put this on to about 50%.
Andrew: How you lift fair news up, Slash down there. Okay. So change right there and left, right to like 55%.
Andrew: And that's really interesting. It didn't actually start narrating the changes until I stopped and use the to read the line command, which is Jaws key, plus the I button
45.
Andrew: But it is narrating when I change it now with the up and down error keys. So i'm going to go ahead and leave one I'm. In, which is called Forums mode. Just how Jose and or next to the form Solomon like that.
Andrew: And then i'm gonna move up.
Andrew: Why, my line? Oh, you, let's tell you. Left 5, 45, i'm gonna hit play
and their hot button to activate Present
Andrew: one is a web developer from table on video adding level 2 as a web developer, Video: transcript button collapsed heading Level 2: what is web developer? Yeah. Video: Transcript: next activity button. Previous activity button, and once again the controls had disappeared, and then the transcript button collapsed. Heading level. 2 one is web developers are sure gating ensure on the heading, and we're getting started in the web development and in level 3
Andrew: heading level 5. But the expand is getting started in the web developers. And I live activity List of 5 by the link of the Web developer, and in the outline series, which are heading and getting started with me as co-feting level 0, so like 5 activities on heading level, 5 button collapse getting started with Github zeros, and that in 0 so shift to it
Andrew: 10 years ago. I guess that seems still be in the outline. What is the web developer heading Level 2. So it's sure. Heading again. Button collapsed at in level 2, with with no connectivity. But all right, I'm going to try hitting F 5 to refresh the page and hopefully that'll keep me in the module with the players. Stop at 5
Andrew: getting started the Web Development vertical. All right. I'm gonna hit control this stuff just for narrating. I'll go to the top with control, and i'll hit each your heading
Andrew: until I find a heading. That sounds like the main activities section right from, and it getting started side menu that course I like that. It getting started, and Web, getting started getting started with it, getting started with it, getting started with Github heading level, fat, wrapping up.
Andrew: getting started with it. Okay, there we are. I think this is about where it was. 0 slash 5 activities on petting level. 2 activity same page links to the course. Cutting Level 2. What is the web? Develop a button?
Andrew: All right, so i'm not going to bother with that player I's 543 volume left there, and he was to the captions. But settings button collapsed, and for a picture attached to that picture button, and they're false to video transmission activity, button previous activity. But
Andrew: that's problematic. I don't know why the controls seem to keep disappearing every time, but they're completely gone. Once I hit that play button. I'm gonna try acting the video transcript, since it seems to be a close to element. And you see that can display without
Andrew: anything going off. Enter for video transcript, enter main region, video transcript button expanded to the advertising web developer or technology video transcript button expanded the career as a Web development. It takes to work in the field career when I web development or the technology built it 5 years ago, I'm: going to build it today. Okay, so it is displaying the text
Andrew: that's spoken during the video. It's also important to have an attention to the table because it's just this. Maybe when I call a little bit of a If you take a top on the bank and web the details something I like that will be something that might also people that have the mobile device in addition to that. So what I'm gonna do, because I notice that the previous next activity buttons that moves me through this model are buttons.
Andrew: or at least that's how jaws are detecting them. I'm gonna hit B for button and see if those controls are still there. But excellent.
Andrew: So I definitely appreciate that there's a video transcript because I don't know why that player the player controls seem to vanish every time.
Andrew: But at least, that's a good way for me to interact with the video information I need and not have to put the player. So I don't get overwhelmed. But no one said next to the the main region and previous activity. But the main region in the main region is next activity. But so hit enter our next activity.
Video: transcript button expanded, getting started in cutting.
Andrew: although it's up with control.
Andrew: Okay, it's your heading until I get to the main activity section right from getting stuff like my course. I'll get into that in settings. That's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's, it's, it's it's it's it's, it's it's it's it's, it's, it's.
Andrew: i'll download my lines, same page links to the course, outline heading level of the first group of people discussing heading level to web development as a career. But the first group of people discussing something around one person is laptop graphic. I used phrases such as web development or web developer. In this course it is important to keep in mind that those 2 phrases are added to their firms for a wide range of extent building that experience
Andrew: list of 5. I don't pile around both. This might start with a program, manager or business analyst who come holler all around, pile around both. This might start with a program manager or business analyst who comes up with a list of 5 items all around. Both. This might start, call around Bullet Designer would typically then figure out how I don't know what happened. For some reason just seemed to read the same bullet a couple of times as if they were separate
Andrew: different lines of the bulleted items.
Andrew: I think that might be a glitch with my program, because it did seem to read down the list properly after
Andrew: I went up and down a couple of times to try and read that line again all around. Bullet developer would likely next to start building the exterior along with others all around Bull a while the assurance Engineer Tester would typically be involved to find issues left paradox right pile around both marketers, lawyers lowest and heading level 3 web developments in the today's world this morning, of course, today, maybe the company is all services for these needs, but they will still continue. Move down line by line. I'm just gonna skim through this content. I'm: development obvious phone competing network into the tech heading Level 3. We're to begin working at at first to figure out which of those enrollment that leads gain in knowledge, or it maybe shift this and have a goals at the ending level for how to learn
Andrew: It just seems like there's a heading structure here. So i'm going to actually just sh shift, plus each real quick to see if there it just to text it. Sometimes things that are tagged as headings that the
Andrew: or other things that just reads is a heading. It doesn't actually detect, with hot keys where to be contending level, 3 web development is more than Webinar to the contending level for you how to learn that in level, okay, perfect, it is detecting those headings when you have access to, or take another step such as learning to be the source code of a favor to this out how much of link level you read the research in the when you add it's getting a book to their destination again. That's really that next activity. But so again i'm just skimming down line by line, and I seem to have the activity button. So i'm just skimming down line by line, and I seem to have the activity button. So the next activity. But so again i'm just skimming down line by line, and I seem to have
video transcript button collect
getting started the web. Same page links diplomat
Andrew: H for heading, and then it's it's it's it's it's getting getting same page links to the course I would like.
Andrew: Now I will let you down, down, line by line with the down Arrow key, button.
Andrew: heading level a button. Can we have another video for Chris R. Rock, by Sparta? 3, 38 volume left there, and he was upsetting his captions button settings. But
and for picture touch and dash, click, enter full screen button.
Now it did make the command. The
Andrew: player controls going in the last 2 videos. Video transcript button collapsed.
Andrew: but also trying to ref to the page with with the F 5 key didn't seem to lose my place, so I will try playing it, just to see if this one's any different. But so his ship will be until you get the play button to the captions, probably in left there, and he was up Slash now. There. Okay, so change right there, Button
lay. But
and their main reason for no player button.
Andrew: PC: Cursor seems virtual. PC. Cursor seems to be so so hit slap in the top, retro at a level to getting some red rabbit to the out of the Vesco and get activity heading level to video transfer button collapsed. Cutting Level 2 Vs. Code and the same pagely cutting levy. No transcript mix activity. But okay, Yup once again. The controls is screwed up for a second. Joseph
getting started in web development.
Andrew: All right. There we go.
Andrew: and what? Oh, and it looks like it loaded My, the virtual PC. Chris's focus right on the play button, so i'll just move down my my line. I'll just move down my my line.
Andrew: and that appears to be the whole activity. So hit next activity button.
Andrew: So i'm, i'm not going to check out if there's any more video players. I'm not going to bother checking them because they seem to all be the same every time I hit play the control seem to go away until I hit f 5 to refresh the page, and then it's not playing anymore. But at least I had the button controls again.
Andrew: I don't know what's going on there. It might be some sort of integration issue with Vimeo.
Andrew: since it seems to be where the videos are from, i'm not sure, but i'm adding up getting started on website. But you had a course I was like getting started and web develop. I'm just saying it's your heading until it gets the main activity getting started getting started with me at getting started with it up and wrapping up heading like
Andrew: that. That is very frustratingly. Honestly, i'm glad that that video transcript is there, because otherwise i'd have no way to interact with those videos.
Andrew: I'm also absolutely had the time to sit down and just do absolutely nothing else to work on this course. Same page. We skip the course outline, which I know would be the optimal situation, but like does like to interrupt from time to time. So it'd be great to have a way to pause the video adding, Level 2. That's like a 0, one full Screen Button World Institute on Disability Graphic. Next Image Button
World Institute on Disability Graphic.
Andrew: Okay. So for 3 button
heading level, 2 tests like a 0, one same page link, skip the post outline.
Andrew: Okay, i'm a little confused for a moment. There, I thought I had another player, but it looks like it's actually an image
Andrew: full-screen world Institute on disability.
Andrew: Next image list of 2 items go to image one button.
Andrew: build the image to button with that next activity button with that build image. Okay, there needs to be a little more instruction on one on earth. I'm supposed to be doing here, because right now i'm at a loss. Build image, one button list of 2 items: next Image Button World Institute on Disability Graphic.
Next image Button.
Andrew: I'll try hitting next semester and see what happens, and the World Institute on Disability Graphic World Institute on Disability.
Andrew: or some kind of instruction here to let me know what i'm supposed to be doing with these the Slider and the images.
Andrew: and then the pages slowing slowly for moment. There! I thought the button didn't do anything.
Andrew: so go to the top of control.
Andrew: and i'm going to actually use a
Andrew: an in Bill Jock it's command called heading list.
Andrew: Josh version 2,022.2 2 and 7.2 5 ilab Munner-in-law Button, select the form field dialogue with this mistake, and it's starting with Thes code Josh version 2,022.2207 point 2, 5 by 11, heading with dialogue, editor.
same page, we skipped the course. I will, adding level 2 in production to the S code
visual studio, local and screenshot of the application interface with extensions in the left side panel, with opencode files on the right to graphic visual studio code left pair known as the S. Code. Right there in the free light we open that source text center by Microsoft that is available for windows, Linux and Mac OS heading Level 3 install and configure label signal code list of 7 items. One visitor.
Andrew: Okay. So it looks like we have an activity based on Vs code, and it's explain what that is.
Andrew: I will say. The L text on this page is much better than the last one, because it's actually telling me a little bit of what i'm looking at for the image of the Vs code they have displayed.
Andrew: Click on Multi-s code left pair, and open 3 follow the windows download link on the page to get a copy of visual studio code. When 4 locate to download numbers of 5 lunch and the user license noon, unless you will also faster to 6. Button 56. If you want to dive right into the program, leave the check box check for lunch into the program on the final install screen, and it's. This is telling me how to go to a different page and install the actual study, but it's it's telling me how to go to a different page and install the actual study. But it's it's telling me how to go to a different page and install the actual study, but it's it's telling me how to go to a different page and install the actual study
Andrew: going down line by line. It's in the Oak 7. When you launch the program you're talking about how you send heading level 3 settings in the field. The timeline also talks about You Go over moving to control, and you can last on using the activity
getting started with me as code article.
Andrew: And again i'll just go ahead and open Josh version 2,022.2, 2, and 7.2, 5. I am getting started with Thes code vertical power table at scale
getting started with a
Andrew: Oh, this gave myself up. In the fourth one went again. Josh version 2,022.2, 2, 7, point, 2, 5 bylab, heading with dialogue.
Andrew: and i'll start moving down line by line. Same page links to the competing level to navigate in the Atl Button for Chris art play. But for Chris progress, 622 following lift their news up to 2 captions. But in that settings button to enter a picture, that's a match picture of the full screen video transcript button collapsed. And then we've got another video. That's activity. But i'm just going to ahead and move past that
Andrew: next activity
window transcript button, collect.
Andrew: page, and one for Josh version, 2,022.2, 2, 7, 7, point, 2, 5 by 11, heading this dialogue, and and once again i'll open the heading list. I'll hey for a day. I didn't call it
Andrew: what this features is it displacing tireless to headings to the page, and then, using this feature, I can go ahead. This new activity. Call it to kind of move that button. I can just jump straight into the heading, since I know that the activity heading is what starts the main focus in the module.
Andrew: It's a handy feature in Joseph. Let me skip a whole bunch of information.
Andrew: Same page. We'll skip the course outline. So i'm just gonna move down one by one at a level. 2 writing code play button request for 540. Probably you left you with caption settings. Button collapsed after a picture intervals for video transcript. But another video, I guess, on writing code that's activity. But
getting started with me as code article
Andrew: and heading to this new red rum called on Scanner, and the headings of activity move to adding button to active space and for editing to activity. Same page we'll skip the course, outline heading level to revealing code play button.
Andrew: So I guess we have another video. That's how we're reviewing
video transfer button
getting started with credit.
Andrew: It's it's it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a
Andrew: cutting level, rewrite some code in the explore. When you launch visual studio code that will open a couple of files by default. These and more details on using the program in some sample in in areas, the drivers for Don't apostrophize the triphs for purposes of explorations. We are going to ignore those items from now. Risk control, plus a 4, a few times to close any open files, respond on to master list of 5 items, one press control placento. Okay, this is just telling me. I guess some sample things one can build in the studio. Oh, free up with the web phone, and my thought was that heading Level 3, creating the doing the Webinar, not with the one to copy and place the one I can't. This is just telling me, I guess some sample things one can build in this studio. Oh, free up with the web.
Andrew: So what i'm going to use. I'm gonna hit B for button.
Andrew: And then i'm going to move offline by line. It will take you to the visual studio, compareding level 3 configuration and preferences.
Andrew: Okay, so it's just telling you more how to configure the studio that I would have downloaded if I was all in this course, so i'll hit B for button Button
getting started with Github vertical.
Andrew: and once again I will open the headings here. Josh version 2,022.2207, point 2, 5. Ilab Redram call into heading with dialogue
Andrew: That's the that's the that's the that's the that's the that's the that's the that's the
getting started with. Get up for
Andrew: getting started with the the new red remaining here a activity polling to move the any button to activate the better heading level. 2 activity same page will skip the course, outline heading level to reposit, to play button
request, progress, 547,000 reference captions, but settings button to enter a picture that's your dash. Enter False video Transcript. Next activity button.
Andrew: I am. We have another video. So i'm just going to skip past this.
Andrew: I don't know how many activities are on this first module. It just seem to be an off a lot getting started same, so i'll go ahead and the heading See again. Josh version 2,020,
Andrew: The activity button
Andrew: in our next activity, because we once again at the sum total is just another video
Andrew: getting started with it up for Josh version. 2,020 to open the headings here, hey? For
same page links to the heading Level 2 submitting an issue.
Andrew: Okay.
heading Level 2. Submitting an issue.
Andrew: I guess this must be for submitting an issue and get
Andrew: which is a club stolen, and it does open properly when I hit, enter on it. Video: Can you call it anyone who use the computer program? Those at some time. Software doesn't work quite right. Some people call it a bug. Some people call it it's request. Some people call it just in the millions, no matter what. If we wanted to change again, we were looking at the okay. So yeah, it is, in fact, dealing with issues on Github. So i'll hit be for button next activity button
Andrew: and move on to the next activity by hitting. Enter
video transcript button expanded getting started.
Andrew: I'll go ahead and open the head and see you again. Josh version 2,022.2, 2, 7.2 5 by 11 heading with dialogue, a activity button to activate and for heading level 2 activity
Andrew: same page links. Get the phone down line by line at in level 2. Try it yourself, Github. Heading level 3 sign up for guitar, although isn't it for creating list of one navigate link to 2 list of holl around all around Bolton, you may be prompted to complete a Captcha and all the all around Bulletin. You may be prompted to complete a captcha, and on the all around Bulletin you may be prompted to complete a Captcha and all the all around Bulletin. You may be prompted to complete a captcha, and on the all around Bulletin you may be prompted to complete a captcha, and on the all-around bullet confirm your eclipse and missed list end heading level 3 private guit up to the github and link tutorial explaining many of the key concepts, for
whether you simply read through the steps or complete them, you will learn the basics of repository's, apostrophe branches, changes where you fill in the cluster of his terminology Left-paren.
Andrew: Okay, we have a clause, 3 for Github terms and once again, very glad that it mentions it opens in the in tamp. One read, or completely tutorial to study the cluster, send heading level 3 browser repository as the striped into its link up there and opens new app, right parent.
Andrew: a reposit documentation for software. You may use the same list of to item one link at the app match for 2 link accessibility and a match for list of for all around Boeing Link navigate to the Nvda left Parent opens new tab repository. Call around this section to go call around. Both locate the Repository Navy data section to go to different areas of a project call around both locate the repository navigation area. This is
Andrew: this section took out a different okay, alright, so it's just me feeling. I understand the information properly. Not any accessibility prompts all around. Both. Choose the issues link for the Nbda Repository, your navigate the link. Http is all around. Both follow the link for an issue with the link Position last an example. Listen: missing list.
Andrew: All right. I'm just gonna continue having in down line by line, setting level 3 clone repository, using the github and multiple. I mean their github that's linked to the desktop. Application for it. I'll try it here in your heading. It sounds like there's settings here right in the top Red Room, and I guess it was
Andrew: below the bottom of this one right to go to that heading the desktop. It's not the only wait list of 7 to one. It's 2 free, and for any virtual 4 to it, like with the one like all around both one. It means that you want to list that 5 of call around, pile around, and we have a bolted list of the sub bullet and jaws is detecting the difference. So that's good
browser by list of to my call around Bullet Hole around with and the next activity button
Andrew: no hand in our next
wrapping up Vertical Park labs.
Andrew: Looks like we may have finished the module. So
Andrew: i'm going to go to the top of control home, wrapping up for
Andrew: hey? It's your heading. I could use the heading to you, but I think there's different information on this page, and I don't want to actually jump to the wrong thing.
Wrapping up heading level one
Andrew: all right. Snow moved down one by line from the scrapping up, heading I here heading level two-sight menu, heading level, 2 same LED and heading 5 heading level. 5 button collapsed, getting started with Thes Code 5 spending the 5 setting 1 0 list of linked top and buildings and apps and linked up the killer test in Portland Pathway linkage as a bill with end heading level to activity. Same page would skip the course, outline cutting level 2 top hunting, play, button.
request our practice. Our left-hand side or 0 by 4, 31.
Andrew: Okay. And we have a player here about jump on thing
Andrew: volume left there through the captions button settings button to enter a picture. That's an enterprise for video transcripts activities like the main region, the main region and main regionet. Okay, i'm confused because it said that this is wrapping up. But i'm seeing something about job hunting. The next activity Button video transcript button collapsed.
Andrew: I'll open the video transcript that made me to middle transcript button expanded. I like anyone. Don't have time when i'm looking for a new top. I think i'm in the transcript button expanded. I like anyone Don't have times when i'm looking for a new.
Andrew: Apparently this is the final section of the first module.
Andrew: I think
Andrew: it would have been
Andrew: better if it was clear. This is like the final section in D outline, or or that first page, cause
well, the tile just say ramping up it doesn't seem like there's any kind of
Andrew: quiz or anything to let me know where i'm at. I I honestly just feel like i'm in another portion of the same module, just just like any of the other pages.
Andrew: So what I'm going to do is i'm going to go to the top, and i'm going to look for a link that says something like courses or main page, or something like that same page linked to the main content Main, i'm just gonna do that by going to top with control home. And now which I did. And now i'm going to go down line by line
Andrew: navigation region. So there's a home link. I want to see it's just like an actual courses. So I don't have to train
Andrew: to figure out. Okay, excellence like that link courses. I'll hit. Enter on course. That's not a region navigation region list with the like. Of course it's vertical Barway Port, and then i'll hit. I'll go to the top of the control.
Andrew: I'll hit each for heading. It's it's getting left my available. It's it's it's it's it's it's already competing, and I'm just gonna keep hitting each your heading until I find that getting served with development. I was just looking through advocating for work and getting started the Web Development heading level freely. Here we are welcome to getting started in web development
Andrew: overall progress, calling 65% complete.
Andrew: That's really interesting, because I don't know if that first module is like most of the course, or that's just like one of several sections.
Andrew: It didn't seem like there was any like major
Andrew: pause, point, or quiz, or something
Andrew: for the next to to kind of
Andrew: put into that first module, if you, as it were.
Andrew: so overall.
Andrew: the actual information itself
Andrew: is pretty accessible. I can get through the text, no problem. There are video transcripts for each of the video players screen.
Andrew: The video plays themselves there some sort of bug or problem going on with them where once they enter to play a video.
Andrew: the actual controls themselves seem to finish, and there's no way for jaws to detect that those player controls are still there.
Andrew: so I either have to refresh the page to stop it, or I have to move on to the next lesson, which
Andrew: not great
Andrew: other than that.
Andrew: It's it's very, very accessible. So
Andrew: thank you very much for listening.